that phrase again what was it you can't
feel your own handshake
when did you hear that that's a
fascinating thing you know i don't
remember the first time i heard that but
i
i loved it when i heard it it just
rang a bell with me so even when you see
yourself
on camera you really you can't you only
see
the steve tom that you know well exactly
and i think that's true with
with everybody no matter what their job
on a film or a television show is
when i see myself that's why i don't go
to dailies
because i only look at myself
and there's a whole frame of information
there that i'm not seeing because i'm
laser focused on me and i think wardrobe
people look only at the wardrobe and the
hairdressers look only at the hair and
the makeup people look only at the
makeup and
and uh i'm not one of those people who
can see that entire frame of information
in its totality
so that's one reason i i don't like to
go to dailies
so going back to your rehearsal prep
for this role um how much time did you
have before you actually met
this large room of people when when you
got the sides like how much time did you
have to prepare
about a week or i recall yeah
yeah and i only got a few pages of
information i didn't see the entire
script
until after i was actually booked on the
film
um and i treated it like any other
audition
you know i um without the context of an
entire script
you just have to make assumptions and um
make choices based on those assumptions
and that's that's what i did luckily i
made the right one
on that one line so what would your
advice be to other actors who
may be the first one in or maybe they're
not the first one in but they run into
all these things that are like the
these roadblocks and it's frustrating
you know you have someone reading with
you that's
you know doesn't have the right uh
updated sides things like that what's
your
obviously it worked for you well you
know you
you just can't get all flustered in the
room you know
i was thinking about how furious i was
while it was happening
but um you you can't let them see your
sweat
you know so i you just and you have no
choice
no choice but to just go with the
situation and
and that's what i did and i think that
um
that doesn't happen very often that's a
for me
that was a rare occurrence because
usually you know you're in you do your
work you're out and it's
you know just uneventful usually most of
the time
auditions are but you have to go in with
a strong choice
and commit to it and stick to it and
i think that that's a mistake that
a lot of newer actors make especially
when
you don't get to audition very often uh
and
and that is to attach
an importance to the audition that is
way out of proportion to its actual
importance
um you're an actor of course but that's
not all you are
and you can't let this moment in an
audition room define who you are
you're a son a daughter a sister a
brother a father a mother
a friend a mentor whatever you are
you're all those things so be those
things
once you leave that room too i don't
know if i answered your question
yeah you did that's great did you always
think like that i mean it's
great no uh-huh no not at all i mean i
uh when i was brand new every audition
was
nerve-racking it was so important that i
get this job
so important and i noticed after a while
that what i was doing was sort of
dumbing my own audition down um
i was
sort of making myself so bland and
playing it so
safe in the audition room in hopes of
getting that job
that i was taking away every bit of my
uniqueness and quirkiness and weirdness
and vulnerability and everything that
makes me castable
so you know the the one thing i would
tell
actors is don't do that you know
let yourself be you don't be afraid to
fail monumentally in an audition
room don't be afraid and go in with that
choice that you've made and and um
if you fail you fail there'll there'll
be more where that came from
there will but give yourself the
opportunity to be that
quirky crazy wonderful psychotic
uh weird person vulnerable person that
will ultimately make you castable
when did that change for you it took
about a year and a half
two years yeah i'm not a fast learner
well i think some people they never
learned i mean it's almost like dating i
know i've said this before but
when someone's taken you know then all
of a sudden they're very attractive to
the opposite sex or
same-sex or whoever but then because you
don't need it as badly so then
where did you get to that point where
you realized i still want to do this
this is why i'm here in la
but i i don't know i'm assuming you
still wanted it
as badly but you realized i'm
more than just this actor coming in to
read i'm a human being i'm a lover of
birds
a lover of different things i'm a fly
fisherman
i love the outdoors i love all kinds of
things
other than this and i think
to to be a well-rounded actor you have
to be a well-rounded person too
and so kids stay in school um
i i joke about that but truly um
yeah live your life live life travel
meet interesting people go to
interesting places do
unusual things that will expand your
horizons as a human being and and
along the way you'll you'll turn into
an interesting person yeah and i think
that's
really important and and i've always
sort of tried to do that and
i think it's helped
you